it's easy to point out the successes
right we and I think that's the the
dangerous thing with nostalgia these
days is like we look back and say oh you
know the the 50s were so great yeah if
you were a white male in the 50s right
and even then it wasn't awesome either
because what if you were working in a
coal mine like yeah there are these
things where you let you you you look
back to to the past and you tweeze out
only the good things that you remember
mm-hmm and you leave behind all the the
the actual the reality of the situation
because reality is this commingling of
good and bad and pleasure and suffering
and everything in between and the stal
just plucks out the things that are
conveniently pleasurable yeah but one of
the things this is like a total aside
but one of the things when people are
like oh yeah the good old days the good
old days people used to be so you know
community oriented in like you know you
knew your neighbor and like I just want
to ask whoever is saying that like what
when's the last time you've went out and
done something for your community like
when's the last time you went to meet
your neighbor and let me just say your
point that people remember how they want
to remember it yeah yeah and they want
to throw blame on how things used to be
versus how they are now and I guess this
is my way of saying like we are in
control of how we use our time our
attention and now can be the good old
days to now will eventually be the good
ones right yeah we're the bad old days
if we if we choose the wrong path
you